hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen leute zu einem neuen video
gibt irgendwann mal vor zehn jahren
weltweit haben hoch geladen wo ich euch
gesagt habe schreibt immer ein paar
fragen die kommentare die beantworte ich
jetzt hier kannst du mal wieder über
dich an fakten video machen bitte mir
machen fakten videos extrem viel spaß
also ich hab bisher glaub ich auf meinem
youtube kanal schon drei oder vier stück
hochgeladen auch teilweise oder
spezielle themen wie beispielsweise
irgendwie 20 gaming fakten über mich
oder sowas wenn ihr also mal wieder so
ein paar sachen über mich erfahren würde
dass ich darüber sage wie quick facts
about me oder irgendwie sowas dann zeig
mir mal mit einer bewertung wenn ihr da
total ausrastet dann werde ich
vielleicht in israel dann fakten wie
hoch man vielleicht auch jetzt dann aus
dem urlaub woher bekommst du deine video
ideen das fragen mich enorm viele weil
ich bin ja jetzt kein mensch der
irgendwie jeden tag minecraft projekt
und noch ein anderes game project
hochlädt sondern der hat schon so zwar
auch ein daily uploader irgendwie einer
gewissen form des obwohl es halt oft
nicht so ganz klar dass mit dem video
ideen ist echt immer so ein thema wo
sich sehr viele fragen hey wie kommen
sie eigentlich darauf dass du jeden tag
wichtig irgendwas neues findet was du
hoch leder beispiel einem halben jahr
angefangen wir so eine google tabelle zu
machen und zu pflegen
die hat ihm einen ablaufplan darstellt
auf diese tabelle kann nicht mehr
zugreifen von meinem weg von meinem
macbook von meinem iphone wenn ich hier
irgendwie unterwegs bin oder so und
immer wenn ich irgend etwas sehe oder
ich irgendwas bei youtube see oder
irgendwo was mitkriegen trennen
mitkriege denke ich mir käfig aber damit
ein video machen oder ist es was ich
scheiß egal ob ich gerade in der bahn
sitzen im auto sitze oder irgendwo zu
hause sitzen sondern dann schreibt uns
einfach direkt da rein und danach ist
die idee quasi vorhanden die meisten die
den kommerz und beim einschlafen und
unter der dusche
man kann dazu echt keine goldene regel
festhalten von gegen ja wenn man dass
das um das zu mittag isst dann kommt man
auch die perfekte video idee ich sehe
meine videos auch niemals perfekt an
aber das mit dem video ideen ist
eigentlich recht simpel
wenn man allein so ein bisschen
nachdenklich mal das eigentlich locker
flockig hinweist du bist schön du bist
hässlich nicht spaß wie du mit deiner
schwester machen nein es hat sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich sehr böse an wenn ich das
einfach so klipp und klar sagen habe ich
werde nie ein video mit einem
familienmitglied von mir machen
das finde ich ein bisschen zu privat ich
habe schon nebels auf videos mit kumpels
gemacht irgendwie mit chris damals in
roter oder kumpel von mir oder allein
mit max und sebastian also mit granie
und escape das sind halt einfach gute
kumpels von mir mit ihm mache ich gerne
videos allerdings ist es bei meiner
familie so dass ich nicht möchte dass
man genau ist über die weiß also wie sie
aussehen wie alt sie sind wie sie heißen
wo sie boden und ich hoffe ihr
respektiert diese entscheidung muss
allerdings auch dazu sagen dass sich
menschen immer ab und an ändern also
wenn ich irgendwann in 40.000 jahren
doch ein video mit meiner schwester
aufnehmen sollte dann war er weist mich
hier nicht zurück auf dieses video
sondern habe ich bestimmt noch andere
gründe oder irgendwas arbeitet bisher
erst mal nein
let's move an wo warst du als gott die
erde verteilt hat das was gesagt wen mag
so von kohle die balu vitello und
kollegen am meisten die sache ist dass
dieses komplette rollenspiel mäßige was
er früher meinen videos so übel krass
für euch angekommen ist derzeit gar
nicht mehr so richtig aktuell am start
ist ich weiß auch früher hat sich balu
vitello kollege einfach im hintergrund
von der camps hat sich irgendwie so nach
und nach alles über diese akinator
videos entwickelt als dann aber immer
mehr youtuber irgendwie akinator
hochgeladen haben habe ich gedacht wenn
es jetzt alle machen hab ich auch keine
lust mehr drauf und dann ist das ein
bisschen runtergegangen mit der
rollenspiel sache dann kam doch der
goalie die blockade der zeit dann immer
noch bei marvin ist weil wir diese serie
auf jeden fall ein bisschen
aufrechterhalten wollen aber die frage
bezieht sich darauf wen ich am meisten
markt und ich glaube das ist dass ich
sogar mein neuer kaktus ein paar
sekunden später das hier ist mein neuer
kaktus namens kaka den abi auch auf du
scheißt missgeburt den kaktus habe ich
mir bei ikea gekauft und das ist ein
echter kaktus also der ist es ist halt
der einzige von den ganzen leuten den
ich bisher namen gegeben habt ihr
wirklich lebt also erlebt hat nicht
wirklich er ich muss ihn einmal im monat
leasen und vielleicht erst seit einem
jahr einmal im halben millimeter
gewachsen aber kaká ich mag a derzeit am
liebsten kratzt halt einfach auch dass
es mittlerweile schon kaka fanpages auf
instagram gibt ihr seid ist eine bis zu
kohl oder doch das wie groß bist du wie
groß und deine muskeln ich bin 192 groß
glaube ich oder 193 irgendwohin drehe
ich hab ich schon länger nicht gemessen
allerdings wachse ich halt nicht mehr
wirklich wäre auch schlimm wenn ich bei
192 noch wachsen würde
ich wünsche kaka wird mal so groß werden
wie muskeln
keine ahnung ich habe keine muskel
glieder muskel dein lied wann kommt
dieses video endlich und sie stellst dir
dein leben in zehn jahren vor erste
seiner ganz kurz beantworten ist jetzt
nicht so dass ich ihnen wie instagram
bild vor drei tagen gesagt habe ich auch
schon immer fragen darunter sondern das
bild ist glaube ich schon drei wochen
her und da wundert wie viele fragen
untergestellt ich wollte nur diesmal ein
bisschen länger warten und die verfault
aber ich wollte länger war aber ich war
faul
hauptgrund war aber ich wollte ein
bisschen faul wie stelle ich mir mein
leben mit zehn jahren vor alter ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung ich hasse solche
sachen komplett zu planen gegen die aber
wenn jetzt der zeit
ein wunsch von mir gebe wie man leben in
zehn jahren sein sollte dann irgendwie
mit einer frau und mit einem kleinen
sohn einer penthouse wohnung in london
kann ich das bitte so haben wie viele
pokémon hast du ich weiß nicht ob zu dem
zeitpunkt wo das video jetzt hier raus
kommt schon ein neuer pokémon gold teil
von mir online ist mein gott ich mache
den flugmodus beim war die ganzen leute
rum so sieht pokémon gerade bei mir aus
also das ist sind so meine besten leute
ich bin 14
mit fast 15 ich habe gerade in meinem
team 48 von 250 punkten und wenn ich auf
pokédex clique dann ich verkrieche mich
ganz als 2000 jahre später so irgendwie
gefangen 50 gesehen 52 also noch nicht
so ultra classic spiels doch nicht so
häufig weil ich derzeit auch was jetzt
kommt in topf seiner nähe macht ja
gerade so dass ich jedes pokémon fange
was ich sehe also jedes format o jedes
haus jedes rad franz und verschicke
direkt an die professor das heißt ja
irgendwie so 250.000 phuket bonbons und
jemand wie ich sein hat alles auf sie zu
entwickeln und dann glück sei einsetzen
dann schaffe ich locker fünf live weil
ich hab irgendwie noch zwei drei klicks
eier und wenn man weiter mit den fragen
warum bist du so dumm
hab dich lieb dankeschön ich hab ich
auch lebt und auch eine ganz kurze sache
an alle instagram pages von mir da
draußen es gibt ja mittlerweile ein paar
seiten die haben irgendwie 30 caps oder
so und die posten halt regelmäßig
irgendwelche ausschnitte von mit
ausbildern burg beispielsweise und dann
schreibe ich als ein text über luca
freut sich dass er gerade eine 21 in der
schule bekommen oder sowas feiere ich
übe ich kann jetzt garnicht ganzen namen
nennen da gibt es ein laser lukas day
oder conny momente
lübz - oder so viele sachen das feiere
ich mega wenn irgendwie so sachen von
mir nicht so komisch bearbeitet werden
mit so herzlichen an uns und das ist
auch schön aber so er so witzig wie wenn
ich ihnen geboten mache und dann
schreibe ich etwas über luca in klammern
20 jetzt der beste pokémon trainer oder
so das war ja ich übel und da freue ich
mich einfach mal ganz gut zu bedanken
das nehme ich damit zu machen bringen in
welchem fach warst du der schule am
besten ich war den religionen letzten
also ich kann halt immer sehr viel über
kontroverse themen reden und mit anderen
darüber diskutieren und deswegen konnte
ich das wasser das einstige fach wo ich
laber ankommt und lagern und lagern oder
das meeting lehrer zurück gekündigt
meinte und meinte von wegen das gedicht
musst du aber so teuer weil es zwar
richtig aber meist richtiger würdest du
dir bei deinen gedanken auf papier
bannen können oder deine träume nachdem
sie geträumt hast noch beim fernsehen
sehen können definitiv das zweite ich
träume immer so eine abgefuckte scheiß
und ich würde das so gerne am nächsten
tag einfach so stell ich vor ihr wacht
auf und wirst du keine chance hatten
wieder ein albtraum oder richtig schönen
traum oder richtig verrückten trauben
noch richtig witzigen traum schalte den
fernseher an und lädt den trauben noch
mal das fände ich ultra geil wenn euch
das video gefallen hat würde ich mich
safe lasten leid da lebt das leben
richtig schwer